bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans sa vous regarde ce
soir le plus grand scandale de la 5e
République ce sont vos mots Vincent
Duclerc bonsoir bonsoir et merci
beaucoup d'être notre grand témoin ce
soir le grand scandale c'est la
responsabilité de l'État français dans
le génocide au Rwanda vous êtes
historien vos travaux font autorité sur
le sujet la France face au génocide des
touts chez taayandier c'est la
prolongation de votre rapport remis au
chef de l'État en 2021 vous avez
revisité l'intégralité des archives on
va en parler génocide un mot aussi que
l'on retrouve beaucoup hein ces
dernières semaines dans le débat public
avec le retour des guerres vous nous
direz ce que vous en pensez tout à
l'heure notre grand débat ce soir la
crise du logement est-elle une fatalité
avec la hausse des taux d'intérêt le
marché de l'immobilier est complètement
bloqué Gabri Gabriel Atal promet un choc
d'offre et suscite la polémique sur le
logement social le Premier ministre veut
faire rentrer le logement intermédiaire
dans les cotas de HLM par commune les
plus pauvres vont-ils trinquer nous en
débattons avec mes invités dans un
instant sur ce plateau enfin nos
affranchi ce soir le billet d'humeur de
Bertrand Perrier le mot de la semaine de
Mariette d'rygrand et puis action
planète c'est la chronique du vendredi
de Léa Falco voilà pour le sommaire on y
va Vincent Duclerc ça vous regarde ça
commence
maintenant
[Musique]
c'est une bombe sociale dont les
déflagrations touchent toute la société
française que l'on soit étudiant ou
jeune actifs riche ou pauvre en HLM ou
en location privée la crise du logement
a des répercussions sur des pans entiers
de la vie quotidienne et pour y remédier
Gabriel Atal a fait des annonces cette
semaine mais elles ne plaisent pas à
tout le monde bonsoir mod Gatel bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes député
MoDem de Paris vous dialoguez vous
débattez ce soir avec Manuel Domerg
bonsoir merci d'être là directeur des
études de la Fondation abépierre la
fondation qui a remis son rapport sur le
mal logement hier on en dira un mot
bonsoir Yamina Saeb bienvenue vous êtes
économiste à l'OFCE spécialiste entre
autres du logement vous connais hein
comme membre du GC sur le climat mais
c'est du logement dont on parle ce soir
enfin bonsoir Éric alouche bonso
bienvenue directeur exécutif du réseau
de franchise ERA Immobilier c'est un
réseau d'agences immobilières présent
dans toute la France Vincent Ducler le
logement évidemment c'est pas votre
sujet mais ça concerne tout le monde et
c'est un sujet technique donc n'hésitez
pas à intervenir si vous avez besoin de
précision un peu de pédagogie avec avec
nos invités on commence par planter le
décor l'ampleur de la crise les
solutions du Premier ministre c'est dans
le recap de Bruno donet bien
sûr et bonsoir mon cher Bruno bonsoiram
bonsoir à tous vous vous êtes plongé
donc à la fois dans les chiffres et dans
les archives de la politique du logement
pour établir un état des lieux
exactement etpreuve que le sujet n'est
pas neuf myiam je vous propose de
commencer par un document sonore il date
d'il y a tout juste 60 ans et celui qui
fait alors trembler les ondes de Radio
Luxembourg s'appelle la baé pierre mes
amis au
secours une femme vient de mourir gelé
cette nuit à 3h sur le trottoir du
boulevard
sébastopool hiver 54 la crise du
mallogement s'invite à la radio le
problème et bien c'est que 70 ans plus
tard elle y est toujours écoutez ça
s'est passé ce matin sur franceInfo nous
avons un grave problème de logement et
c'est pas simplement moi qui qui le dit
la Fondation àépierre parle d'une année
noire pour le logement une année noire
pour le logement alors est-ce que c'est
vrai et bien la réponse c'est c'est oui
oui mais c'est pas moi qui le dit le
logement est en crise c'est vrai mais on
a un système qui est un Maqui c'est très
compliqué le foncier est trop cher les
délais sont trop longs tout ça crée du
cût pour nous tous quand on veut
acquérir un logement ou quand on loue
voilà alors pour établir précisément
l'état des lieux hein je suis allé
chercher quelques chiffres s'agissant
tout d'abord du logement social 2
millions et demi de ménages sont
aujourd'hui inscrits sur une liste
d'attentees en 2021 la France a
construit 87000 logement alors qu'elle
en construisait 125000 tous les ans
avant 2017 et sur le front du logement
tout court maintenant et bien là les
difficultés sont absolument partout les
taux de crédit sont passés de moins de 1
% en 2021 à 4 % aujourd'hui les prix des
terrains à bâtir ont été multipliés par
3 en l'espace de 20 ans enfin le nombre
de constructions s'effondre en 2023
373000 logements seulement sont sortis
de terre les spécialistes estiment qu'il
faudrait en construire au moins 450000
tous les ans oui on n'y est Pasin les
chiffres sont mauvais mais ce que les
oppositions au fond reprochent au
gouvernement c'est son inaction oui vous
l'avez entendu he l'insoumise Clémentine
Autin l'a dit il y a un instant mais du
côté des verrs et bien c'est exactement
la même chose il renvoie Emmanuel Macron
à son bilan neuf condamnations neuf
condamnations par la par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme c'est
ce qu'a eu la France sous Emmanuel
Macron pour son inaction face à ses
problèmes de logement alors est-ce que
la France manque d'ambition pour le
logement c'est la grande question
Gabriel Atal le sait voilà pourquoi
c'est avec ce sujet-là qu'il a choisi de
débuter mardi son discours de politique
générale mesdames et messieurs les
députés beaucoup d'entre vous me l'ont
dit s'il est un secteur qu'il faut
déverrouiller c'est bien le logement il
a commencé par la porte en faisant
sauter les verrou très bien et puis et
puis il a eu une autre formule nous
voulons avancer pour un choc d'offre
c'est pour un choc d'offre alors là
qu'est-ce que c'est je ne sais pas ce
que c'est qu'un choc d'offre mais en me
replongeant ce matin dans ma grande
collection d'archives politique j'ai
fait une petite découverte le documents
datent de 2017 un certain Emmanuel
Macron est en pleine campagne
présidentielle il répond à une question
sur le coût des logements et et voici ce
qu'il dit c'est comme ça que vous
réduisez le coû très concrètement c'est
en créant un choc d'offre quel choc en
effet et quelle étrange gémélité alors
le poids des mots vaudrait-il davantage
que le choc des mesures je ne sais pas
je sais simplement qu'aujourd'hui hein
la France n'a toujours pas de ministre
du Logement les grincheux il voilà un
symbole mais ils ont probablement très
mauvais esprit merci beaucoup Bruno
donet pour ce billet fort éclairant mod
de gâel c'est vrai qu'on les alertes
sont là au fond tous les indicateurs
sont au rouge et on a l'impression quand
même que c'est pas son sujet le logement
à son gouvernement certes là enfin
quelques annonces mais il était temps
est-ce que vous n'avez pas sous-estimé
cette crise qui couve depuis bien
longtemps avant même la hausse des taux
d'intérêt alors cette crise elle couve
et effectivement c'est la première
mesure que nous avons demandé au sein du
groupe modem c'est une grande loi
logement parce que le logement bloqué ce
sont des vies qui sont bloquées ce sont
des étudiants qui ne se déplacent pas
pour aller suivre les études de leurs
rêve ce sont des couples qui ne
décohabitent pas parce qu'ils n'ont pas
de perspective
ce sont des travailleurs qui ne prennent
pas un nouvel emploi à cause de cela on
dit même que le trème bébé sur la
natalité ça peut avoir des conséquences
parce qu'on peut pas le loger je suis
députée à Paris et effectivement quand
vous entendez faire un enfant en tant
que couple en général vous quittez la
capitale donc ce ce ce c'est à chaque
étape du parcours résidentiel que c'est
bloqué l'hébergement d'urgence et on
sait à quel point en dépit de
l'augmentation du nombre de places
d'hébergement il y a chaque nuit dans
les rues des familles à la rue sur
l'état des lieux tout le monde est
d'accord mais Bruno donet nous montre
bien avec ce choc d'offre déjà promis
par Emmanuel Macron il y a quelques
années que que ça ne change pas
4500500000 logements nécessaires par an
à construire si vous rajoutez à ça un
marché complètement bloqué on se dit
qu'il y a un problème d'action des
pouvoir public ce choc d'offre
déverrouiller c'est l'idée toutes les
procédures en les simplifiant ça c'est
le nouveau mot magique ça peut marcher
vous y croyez alors il y a beaucoup de
choses qui ont été faites je parlais de
l'hébergement d'urgence et de
l'augmentation du nombre de places
d'hébergement urgence ça ne suffit pas
on le voit tous les soirs néanmoins ça a
été fait mais il y a effectivement il y
a eu début des années 2020
ralentissement effroyable de la mise en
construction ralentissement qui date de
2007 donc ça ne date pas 2017 mais
néanmoins c'est à chaque étape qu'il
faut agir c'est le crédit l'accès au
crédit aujourd'hui vous avez des gens
qui potentiellement auraient les moyens
d'acheter qui ne peuvent pas parce que
les banques verrouille le crédit ça
signifie qu'il reste dans le parc
locatif donc le parc locatif est bloqué
le le logement social moins de 4 % à
Paris de taux de rotation la moyenne
d'âge c'est 50 ans ce qui signifie que
les jeunes couples qui qui débutent les
gens qui prennent
soin de nos enfants de nos aînés n'ont
pas les moyens d'accéder aujourd'hui
vous avez 12000 logements sociaux à
Paris qui sont attribués et vous avez
250000 demandeurs de logements sociaux
donc on voit bien que évidemment ça ne
va pas donc c'est à chaque niveau à
chaque niveau le crédit la
simplification la rénovation thermique
bâtiments parce que on connaît aussi à
la fois l'absolue nécessité et en même
temps le risque d'attrition de
diminution du parc locatif donc c'est à
tous les niveaux qu'il faut agir et
c'est une urgence absolue alors ça y est
on on y est tous hein le Premier
ministre l'a dit le président l'a dit
ERC alouche pour bien comprendre l'état
du secteur on ne vend plus et on nachète
plus alors non c'est pas si simple que
ça on vend toujours on achète toujours
mais effectivement on a on a une
difficulté actuelle actuellement nous
avons effectivement des acquéreurs qui
ont du mal à acheter tout simplement
parce que les les banques pendant
pendant un temps alors ça s'améliore un
petit peu en ce moment mais ne prêtent
pas c'est même pas une question de taux
alors effectivement les taux montent ce
qui provoque une une insuffisance de de
de d'argent pour pour les acheteurs qui
peuvent du coup pas acheter la surface
qu'ils souhaiteraient mais même avec ça
on a des banques qui ne prêtent pas donc
ça c'est un un véritable problème
aujourd'hui et tout ça ça vient de
toujours du même problème qui a été
diagnostiqué de manière très très
précise très pointue très sagace en 2017
par par Emmanuel Macron s'il y a un choc
d'offre il y a un manque de bien tout
simplement effectivement depuis 2017 on
sait mais il se passe quoi il se passe
rien donc il y a besoin vraiment d'avoir
plus de logement sur le marché tout
simplement parce que tout ça ça va faire
baisser les prix ça va avoir un effet un
effet vertueux sur le marché oua alors
on voit bien ce qui se passe parce que
du coup les prix des loyers augmentent
il faut aussi l'expliquer puisque la
demande explose vous dites il faut
construire le foncier le prix à s'est
envolé également les dispositifs fiscaux
pour inciter je je suis pas spécialiste
mais Pinel tout le monde en parle on l'a
on l'a supprimé est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ça
coûte trop cher pour un particulier de
s'engager à acheter un terrain et à
faire construire je crois qu'il faut il
faut travailler sur toute la chaîne du
logement il faut travailler avec les
professionnels surtout ce qui amène à à
produire un logement surtout ce qu' a
des conséquences sur le prix
puisqueeffectivement il y a un problème
de de prix le neuf c'est pas comme
l'ancien dans le UF on dépend du prix
des matériaux alors que dans l'ancien
c'est une question d'offre et de demande
mais il faut fluidifier aussi l'ancien
pour qu'il y ait taux de rotation
suffisante pour qu'effectivement les
gens puissent vendre plus facilement et
acheter plus facilement donc il y a tout
un travail de fond à faire oui oui il
faut construire mais pour l'instant on
vend pas donc on peut se poser la
question vous-même vos agences on sait
que tout le secteur les notaires les
agences immobilières les promoteurs
Nexity le géant de l'immobilier ils vont
ils ont un plan social vous-même vous
allez fermer vous allez non non on n pas
de plan social alors nous sommesité nous
sommes un réseau de franchise donc
effectivement les les agences ont un peu
plus de difficultés en ce moment mais
nous sommes là pour les aider
effectivement et pour le leur permettre
de tenir cette période Emmanuel Domerg
cet état des lieux à nouveau cette crise
c'est en premier lieu les plus modestes
qui qui sont frappés le rapport de la de
la Fondation amvière 15 millions de
Français ont un problème de logement
4100000 mal logés 2400000 sont en
attente d'un d'un logement social en
fait la bombe sociale elle a explosé
cette année oui tout à fait la crise du
logement évidemment ne date pas là d' y
a 1 an ou 2 ans elle date pas de 2017 et
d'Emmanuel Macron mais les choses
s'aggravent et là de manière c'est c'est
assez spectaculaire vous citiez le
chiffre de 2,4 million de ménages en
attente de logement social ça c'était il
y a 2 semaines maintenant c'est 2,6
millions de ménages ça a augmenté de
manière drastique en une seule année en
2023 au début du quinquena d'Emmanuel
Macron on était à même pas 2 millions de
ménages en attente on a rajouté 600000
ménages plus d'un million de personnes
qui attendent un logement social et
pendant qu'elles attendent un logement
social où est-ce qu'elles vivent
certaines vivent dans des conditions
difficiles certaines sont dans des
conditions dramatiques 330000 personnes
sans domicile en France soit en
hébergement soit à la rue des personnes
en bidonville des personnes qui dorment
à la rue des personnes particulièrement
vulnérables qui sont à la rue des
enfants des femmes enceintes des
nourrissons c'est des choses quand même
qu'on ne voyait pas à ce point-là il y a
5 ou 10 ans donc vous êtes d'accord avec
l'objectif il faut construire plus
d'ailleurs pour construire du logement
social aussi et cette idée de
déverrouiller toutes ces procédures qui
seraient trop longu trop contraignante
vous votre archive était très cruelle le
même président en 2017 avait n'avait pas
vraiment d'idée sur le logement simple
idée qu'il avait comme pour tous les
secteurs c'était on va simplifier et
tout va s'arranger est-ce que il a eu 7
ans pour le faire est-ce que tout s'est
arrangé non au contraire c'est pas un
choc de l'offre c'est une chute de
l'offre on est maintenant à 82000
logements sociaux produits en 2023 on
est passé sous les 300000 logements tout
compris mis en chantier cette année
c'est 100000 de moins que l'année
précédente donc évidemment il y a des
normes en France on construit pas des
logements n'importe comment on construit
des logements pour 100 ans vous croyez
qu'on va supprimer l'État de droit et la
possibilité pour les voisins de faire
des recours bien sûr que non on va pas
supprimer les normes de construction
vous savez ils se sont amusés il y a 6
mois à changer une norme à dire ok pour
qu'il y ait plus de logement on va
autoriser les logement avec une hauteur
sous plafond de 1,80 c'est c'est bien ça
c'est intéressant de faire ça peut-être
qu'on aura plus de logement on pourra
pas se tenir debout dedans donc il a un
moment les normes elles protègent aussi
les gens qui habitent le ministre du
Logement qu'on avait avant il faisait 2
m2 il a autorisé des logements dans
lesquels il ne peut pas rentrer debout
non mais il y vivra pas il n vivra pas
parce que les les personnes qui ont des
moyens importants ne sont pas concerné
par la crise du logement les tr/4 des fr
sont satisfait de le
logement class moy supérieur c'est pas
les classes c'est les personnes qui sont
avec des petits salaires ou qui sont
sans domicile Yamina SAE la hausse des
taux d'intérêt n'explique pas tout on
peut le dire comme ça elle est pas le
seul facteur responsable de la crise
elle date de bien avant qu'est-ce qui
fait queon a ce problème un peu
endémique depuis tellement d'années en
France parce que tout simplement le
logement qui est le lieu de vie des gens
est devenu un actif et donc on a finan
cialisé on a on a fait de du foncier
c'est
devenu une valeur financière et la même
chose du logement on a supprimé les
aides à la puissance publique on a cassé
la puissance publique qui produit du
logement pour le les citoyens modestes
et on on a augmenté il y a tellement de
niches fiscales pour que des
investisseurs voraces viennent se jeter
là-dedans et donc du coup on on n pas du
tout on est sorti de la logique du du
lieu de vie et et ça c'est c'est le rôle
d'un gouvernement de garantir un lieu de
vie pour chaque citoyen un droit au
logementoitable logement il faut
constitutionnaliser le droit au logement
pour sortir de cette crise c'est la
seule façon en vérité de sortir de cette
crise alors on se souvient d'une
certaine Christine Boutin qui avait posé
la question ce droit opposable ça change
quelque chose si on sanctuarise dans le
la norme fondamentale ce droit écoutez
aujourd'hui pour le rendre effectif pour
les gens vous avez le le le droit au
logement opposable vous pouvez être
connu d'allau et la réalité c'est qu'en
Île-de-France vous avez 12000 personnes
qui sont reconnues d'Allo et chaque
année 2000 personnes simplement qui sont
relogées donc ça existe et d'ailleurs
l'État est condamné de ne pas pouvoir
reloger ces personnes je crois qu'il
faut pas chercher tant des
responsabilité que des solutions
c'est-à-dire comment on fait comment
fait alors donnez-nous un chemin parce
que c'est vrai que j'ai l'impression que
voilà c'est toujours les mêmes débats
l'état des lieux tout le monde est
d'accord les solutions c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué alors on parlait
construction mais il y a aussi remise
sur le marché locatif d'un certain
nombre de biens il y a les biens vacants
évidemment les bureaux alors les bureaux
les les les les les lieux vacants et
puis aussi éviter que c'est
particulièrement le cas à Paris que vous
ayez une fuite vers les meublés
touristiques les meublés de tourisme et
c'est ce qu'on a fait cette semaine avec
en votant la p proposition de loi Airbnb
exactement qui supprime la niche fiscale
pour essayer de libérer du logement pour
les gens qui travaillent et pas
seulement les touristes ça n'a aucun
sens que vous soyez plus taxé en tant
que propriétaire quand vous mettez à la
location pour de la location longue
durée que de la loocation courte durée
mais ça ça résout vraiment le problème
de la crise du logement c'est le
problème il est absolument global
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut agir sur tous
les leviers simplification rénovation
thermique c'est indispensable mais il
faut qu'on simplifie la manière de faire
appel le calendrier l'écologie c'est une
bonne question parce que certes il va y
avoir de la simplification sur ma prime
renove pour remplacer une vieille
chaudière par exemple et en même temps
on sent monter euh des voies qui
s'élèvent sur le DPE là je me tourne
vers l'agent immobilier j'imagine que
vous faites des visites et donc en
permanence on vous dit c classé g à
Paris notamment C classé F et donc vous
pourrez plus le louer à partir de
l'année prochaine ou un peu plus tard
euh il faut changer ça il faut assouplir
le calendrier il faut rendre les choses
possibles pour les propriétaires alors
est-ce qu'il faut changer je sais pas
mais en tout cas quand vous êtes
propriétaire et vous devez faire des
travaux qui représentent plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros vous vous
posez la question soit vous vendez le
bien soit vous faites les travaux si
vous faites les travaux il y a un
certain nombre d'inconvénients si vous
vendez le bien vous prenez votre argent
vous allez le mettre ailleurs qu'est-ce
qu'on veut aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on veut
qu'il y ait moins de logement à la
location à Paris ou pas et si on
effectivement on ne change pas ce
calendrier si on ne permet pas cette
souplesse on aura moins de logement à
Paris alors qu'il y a déjà un déficit du
logement et c'est pas en plafonnant les
loyers que vous allez régler le problème
donc il faut vraiment se poser les
bonnes questions et V le font hein
notamment à Paris à nidalgo plafonne
encadre les loyers vous pensez pas que
c'est une bonne solution mais c'est pas
ça c'est que ça ne résout rien c'est pas
ça qui va amener plus de stock plus
d'offres pour reprendre monsieur Macron
à Paris
oui moi je suis toujours étonnée la
bombe sociale elle concerne les les gens
qui ne sont pas logés ou alors les gens
qui sont mal logés on est d'accord et là
on parle de de crédit donc propriété
privée et on parle de rénovation de gens
qui ont déjà des logements ça c'est un
problème c'est pour ça qu'elle elle
touche tous les public en fait non non
mais mais en fait ce sont ce sont deux
problèmes différents ils sont c'est
grave d'avoir les deux en même temps
mais ce son sont deux problèmes
différents si on construit du logement
neuf il faudra construire des logements
qui soient très basse consommation pour
éviter surtout lorsqu'on construit pour
des des ménages modestes pour éviter
qu'il tombent après dans une situation
de précarité énergétique ils ne pourront
pas payer leur facture énergétique ils
sont des millions de concitoyens ne pas
pouvoir payer leur facture énergétique
maintenant quand on parle du logement
existant il faut rénover aussi au niveau
basse consommation parce que c'est en
particulier lorsqu'on rénove dans le
logement les logements occupés par par
les les les foyers les plus modestes
parce que c'est la seule façon d'éviter
de de réduire le le poids en fait le le
la part du logement dans dans le Budet
le
budgetet% FAM là il y a des familles
quand vous avez votre budget logement
qui représente 50 60 % de ce que vous
gagnez combien il vous reste pour manger
pas rien du tout alors avant de parler
du logement social parce que c'est un
peu la mesure qui qui fâche en tout cas
qui fait réagir un dernier mot alors là
c'est la spécialiste du climat et de la
décarbonation du bâtiment euh Yamina
saeble le Zam vous avez vu les les v de
bouclier sur le zéro artificialisation
nette c'est pour arrêter de bétonner
parce que ça pollue et donc faire en
sorte que soit on construise en hauteur
soit on reste dans les cœurs de villes
euh vous dites qu'il faut continuer ou
il faut entendre aussi ceux qui vous
disent bah si vous voulez construire il
faut dégager des terrains alors on en
fait il y a aussi des chiffres qui
viennent de l'agence de de
l'environnement de de la transition
écologique qui montre qu'il y a 20 % de
logement déjà construit qui ne sont pas
utilisés ou sous-utilisés donc la
première chose à faire si s'ils veulent
faire une offre un choc d'offre ou je
sais plus quelleelle était l'expression
c'est et ben la première chose à faire
c'est de récupérer les logements qui
sont déjà là disponibles de les
récupérer et d'iloger les gens qui n'ont
pas de logement ça c'est la première
chose à faire mais pas toucher à cet
objectif de ça c'est la première chose à
faire ensuite ça c'est les logements qui
sont déjà là en fait ils sont construits
ce sont des logements ensuite on a en
plus des logement ement on a des mètres
carrés qui sont construits qui ont été
construits pour d'autres raisons qui ne
sont plus utilisés ces mètres carrés là
il faudra les rénoverfin les adapter
pour en faire des logements ensuite
vient la question de la question de la
construction en fait elle vient vraiment
en dernier parce que ce qu'il faut
garder en tête dans cette offre de choc
c'est que on construit pas un logement
comme on prépare un gâteau hein parce
que pour construire un logement il faut
moyenne 2 3 ans ça veut dire qu'on
répond pas à la question qui est posée
maintenant pour répondre à la question
qui est posée maintenant il faut
récupérer tous les mètres carrés
existants en faire du logement du
logement basse consommation en
particulier lorsqu'il s'agit des foyers
modestes c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera
qu'on redonnera confiance au citoyens on
sent que voilà ça pourrait même être la
Grande Cause Nationale de ce quinena
alors faut-il ouvrir la loi su qui
oblige les grandes communes à construire
25 % de logements sociaux Gabriel Atal a
suscité la polémique il veut faire
rentrer les catégories intermédiairees
dans les quotas de HLM par commune
explication Clément
per
qu'est-ce que la loi SRU elle date de
l'an 2000 et du gouvernement Jospin la
loi relative à la solidarité et au
renouvellement urbain mieux connu sous
le nom de SRU son principe est simple
obliger toutes les communes situées en
zone urbaine à proposer selon les cas
entre 20 et 25 % de logement sociaux si
ces quotas ne sont pas respectés les
villes doivent payer des amendes que
gabrielal le Premier ministre veut
intégrer à la part obligatoire de
logements sociaux des logements dit
intermédiaire ce sont des logements
destinés aux classes moyenne et moyenne
supérieur qui ont des revenus trop
importants pour bénéficier de logements
sociaux mais qui peuvent avoir des
difficultés à se loger dans le parc
privé quels sont les critères de revenu
des logements intermédiaire il existe
deux types de logement intermédiaire
d'abord le PL la prèlocatif social pour
en bénéficier les plafonds de revenus
nets imposa sont à Paris et région
parisienne de 32715 € pour une personne
seule
48894 € pour un couple sans enfant en
province ces chiffres passent à
28441 € et
37982 €. l'autre type de logement
intermédiaire est le prêlocatif
intermédiaire pli les plafonds sont plus
élevés 393 3 € pour une personne seule
en région parisienne
58831 € pour un couple en province il
existe trois zones géographiques mais le
plafond peut descendre à
28876 € pour une personne seule et 38560
€ pour un couple les logements
intermédiaires existent depuis 2014 ils
sont 10 à 15 % moins chers que les prix
constaté sur le marché libre assez
méconnu il en existe un peu moins de
100000 en France mais mais le
gouvernement voudrait 30000 de plus
chaque année
Emmanuel Domerg vous avez bondi quand
vous avez entendu Gabriel Atal oui parce
que on on la loi sus c'est une loi qui
fait partie un peu du patrimoine quand
même de la nation elle est devenue assez
consensuelle aujourd'hui alors qu'elle a
été combatue par beaucoup de maires qui
ne voulaient pas faire de logement
social et maintenant tout le monde
s'accorde à dire que c'est une bonne
idée de bon sens de répartir les
logements sociaux un peu partout
d'autant plus qu'on a de plus en plus
besoin bon elle est pas respectée
partout et et et là c'était pas du tout
dans les cartons de d'affaiblir cette
loi etu le précédent ministre il y a 3
semaines Patrice vergrit du logement
avait dit la loi SRU j'y tiens comme à
la prunelle de mes yeux c'est moi qui l'
écrite je n'y toucherai jamais et là on
a une annonce sans aucune concertation
pour servir les gens dans votre
reportage vous parlez des gens qui des
logements intermédiaires pls c'est déjà
des logements sociaux là ce qu' veut
ouvrir c'est les logements locatifs
intermédiaires pour des gens qui sont
au-delà des plafonds donc c'est des gens
des 7e et 8e dcil
donnez-nous à peu près un revenu moyen
par mois c'est quoi c'est 2500 € non à
Lyon ou à Lille pour un couple avec deux
enfants le plafond de ressources pour
accéder au logement que ce gouvernement
veut promouvoir c'est 90000 € par an
7500 € par mois en couple on n'est pas
sur des cadres on est sur un couple de
cadres est-ce que c'est eux qui ont
besoin de la politique du gouvernement
il y a 2,6 million de ménages qui
attendent un logement il y a des enfants
qui dorment dehors est-ce que c'est
vraiment juste de se dire on va couper
les vivres du logement social comme
c'est le cas depuis 2017 et au lieu de
les aider au moment où ça se casse la
gueule la production HLM on va aider le
locatif intermédiaire pour les cadres et
les communes qui ne veulent pas
accueillir des pauvres on va leur
permettre de respecter la loi quand même
en accueillant des cadres donc elle est
électoraliste pour vous cette mure elle
est même pas électoraliste
y class moyen supérieur les class Mo cl
moyen supérieur alors M Gatel qu'est-ce
que vous répondez vous êtes député de la
majorité député MoDem il y aura
peut-être une loi logement et il va
falloir voter ou ne pas voter cet
élargissement des critères de la loi SRU
pour y faire rentrer les classes
moyennes parce que c'est c'est ça que
dont il s'agit hein c'est c'est vraiment
à elle que s'adresse le Premier ministre
gouvernement alors c'est aussi comment
est-ce qu'on déverrouille à chaque étape
parce que c'est bien ça la question la
question c'est produire davantage je dis
pas construire davantage je dis produire
d'avantage et ce à chaque étape la la la
la proposition de faire évoluer la loi
SRU il y a aussi peut-être une
conséquence à cela et bien évidemment je
rappelle quand même qu'il y a des il y a
des mesures qui ont été annoncées par
ellisabeth borne au mois de novembre de
dire 50 % de la création de logement qui
sera du logement social donc on revient
pas en arrière par rapport aux an me
troup je vous sens quand même assez mal
àaise avec cette mesure c'est votre
droit le plus absolu
de elle a été annoncé au moins de novemb
fa fa
50 % de la production totale de logement
si annoncé quoi pardon vous ne
connaissez pas le sujet alors produit
300000 logements par an 82000 logements
sociaux est-ce que vous est-ce que vous
êtes en train de dire que le
gouvernement annonce 150000 logements
sociaux par an c'est faux non alors vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure le fait que
en l'occurrence le nombre de mise en
construction était moins importante
cette année que l'année précédante et
l'objectif c'est de remonter la pente
puisque on voit bien qu'on a des
problèmes à chaque étape à chaque étape
du logement par rapport à la loi et s ru
il y a aussi le sujet et vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure la question du
foncier du cout du foncier quand
aujourd'hui vous avez programme qui est
mis en œuvre un programme de mis en
œuvre il y a à la fois il peut y avoir
de l'accession sociale à la propriété et
du social avec plai plus pls la question
c'est le coût Infiné pour le promoteur
entre entre le social et le le
l'accession sociale à la propriété et
donc il faut regarder qu'est-ce qui
permet au maximum de produire du
logement parce que c'est ça et je crois
excusez-moi mais je pense que c'est ce
qu'on veut tous comprend tous sans être
expert c'est c'est que si vous retirez
une part je sais pas si c'est 5 % 10 %
dans les 25 % au plus modeste il vpité
vers il m ils mettent en concurrence les
plus modestes avec les cadres vous
imaginez un peu ce n'est pas du
déverouage que vous allez faire vous
tirez sur la loi vous tirez sur le
pilier de l'égalité de la République
c'est ça que vous allez faire h alors
Éric alouche c'est pas forcément c'est
un débat très politique mais qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ce
qu'il a dit aussi Gabriel hatal c'est il
faut redonner du pouvoir au maire sur le
logement social dans l'attribution et ça
fait très très longtemps qu'il le
réclame et pas seulement au aux officers
HLM aussi au au au maire pour pour mieux
répartir mieux décider de qui habite
dans dans l'habitat social ça c'est un
autre sujet alors je DIRIS il y a deux
sujets alors le premier sur la loiru moi
j'avoue je je je comprends pas trop
parce que vous avez une enveloppe une
casserole disons qui est consacrée au
logement social et vous rajouter
d'autres choses dedans donc forcément il
y a un effet de diluion qui s'opère vous
avez forcément moins de logements
sociaux donc pour moi ça s'appelle un
tour de passe passe effectivement on dit
ça comme on veut hein on emploie le
terme qu'on souhaite mais oui vous avez
tous compris que on faisait entrer dans
les 25 % c'est pas on rajoute plus inér
c'est bien ça qui dont il s'agit c'est
d'intégrer de nouveaux une part de
nouveaux couples voilà avec d'autres
critères sociaux dit autrement madame ça
veut dire réduire la part des logements
sociaux c'est ça ce que ça veut dire
alors qu'on est en plein crise de bombe
sociale quoi alors Éric alouche et vous
répondrez après M Gatel vous TER le
problème pour moi il vient même pas de
là il vient qu'il est absolument anormal
que dans notre pays on puisse pas se
loger et qu'on ait besoin de logements
sociaux le vrai problème il est là
est-ce que l'État va continuer à à à
rendre absolument indispensable la
création de logements sociaux ou est-ce
qu'on va libérer par un choc de l'offre
par exemple les les les créations de
nouveaux logements c'est ça le vrai
problème il est là il faut forcément
choisir on peut faire les deux non ben
on peut faire les deux mais si le
logement privé devient tellement petit
et diminue tellement au détriment du
logement social on change de société on
n est pas encore là M Gatel il faut
forcément une loi pour changer les
critères d'attribution de la loi SRU des
log je le crois
effectivement aujourd'hui on a
5,15 millions de logements sociaux oui
on parlait là de 100000 personnes
environ concernées par le pli je crois
donc vous dites c'est très peu en fait
d'abord changer par ailleurs ilut bien
évidemment enfin moi j'ai toujours été
une défenseuse de la loi SRU et des 25 %
je considère que
tout le monde doit faire sur son
territoire de la mixité sociale au
contraire je suis favorable à ce qu'on
cape le logement social parfois et là
nous ne sonons pas d'accord parce que je
considère que en plus de la c'est-à-dire
que vous avez parfois des des des villes
notamment alors des arrondissement à
Paris vous avez par exemple le 19e
arrondissement à 46 % de logements
sociaux on a besoin d'un accompagnement
par rapport vous dire quoi de la mixité
sociale à l'intérieur même des immeubles
HL alors l'idéal à l'intérieur des
immeubles en tout cas à l'échelle du
quartier et donc il y a aussi cet effort
à faire pour faire en sorte que chaque
territoire prenne sa part aujourd'hui on
est à 17 % il faut atteindre les 25 %
bon le regard de l'historien sur un
débat où forcément la question du
logement est centrale oui en tout cas on
voit il y a une forte intensité du débat
et et ça montre que c'est pas du tout
ENF que c'est bien sûr un un enjeu
technique mais un enjeu universel hein
je pense que les les personnes dans leur
vie intime leur vie sociale ont besoin
on a parlé de lieu de vie c'est très
juste hein et moi je vrais fait
référence à la grande historien Michel
Perou qui a écrit un livre sur
l'histoire des chambres et donc si on
veut que en fait les personnes aux
concitoyens se projet dans l'avenir il
faut qu'ils ait un ancrage voyez et et
cet ancrage il est essentiel pour se
retrouver hein pour avoir de l'équilibre
et donc tout ce qui a été dit bon moi je
je trouve eff très important et
peut-être juste un dernier point sur
effectivement la la position de de de la
Fondation Abé piierre et Maus hein ça
nous renvoie à ce qu'a fait laabé
piierre le 1er février
1954 70 ans 70 ans pardon c'est ça et et
en fait il faut le rappelerin l'abé
pierre était très courageux parce que il
a mis aussi une réputation en jeu et sa
réputation cétait un grand résistant tu
il était très proche de général de
Gaulle et effectivement il met sa
réputation dans une cause extrêmement
forte donc c'est là où on touche
effectivement à l'importance je crois du
sujet h alors quelles sont vos attentes
pour terminer sur cette mesure qu'elle
soit définiement der comb de la baai
pierre 6 mois avant de mourir il est
venu à l'Assemblée nationale ici en
fauteuil roulant parce que a des députés
voulent Dét cô à lo SRU et il a gagné et
je pense qu'on gagnera aussi quelque
chose me dit que c'est pas fait cette
mesure sur le SRU parce qu' il y a une
majorité à l'Assemblée et parfois même
la macronie est fracturée sur les sujets
sociaux on verra bien merci beaucoup on
s'arrête là merci d'être venu débattre
de cette crise de du logement sur LCP
vous restez avec moi Vincent Duclerc
dans une dizaine de minutes les partis
pris de nos affranchis ce soir le regard
de maître Bertrand Perrier sur cette
création d'un homicide routier à
l'Assemblée vous le savez poussé par le
chef étoilet Yanick àeno après la mort
de son fils agriculture c'est le mot de
la semaine de Mariette d'arégrand et
puis de quoi nous parlez-vous les
affalco dans Action planè cette semaine
et ben suf qui peut on va parler de la
dotation de Paris et de la votation sur
les SUV est-ce qu'il faut pénaliser les
propriétaires de très grosses voitures
su SUV suf qui peut bravo pour le jou
pour le weekend merci à tout à l'heure
les amis mais d'abord on va plonger avec
vous Vincent Duclerc dans l'horreur du
génocide au Rwanda 1994 entre 800000 et
1 million de morts en 3 mois votre livre
la France face au génocide des tout s
chez taayandier prolonge donc le rapport
de la commission que vous avez présidé
en 2021 c'est un livre important
essentiel on voit cela dans l'invitation
d'Hélène Bonduel interview juste
[Musique]
après si on vous invite Vincent Duclerc
c'est parce que 30 ans tout juste après
le génocide des tsis et alors que les
Rwandais exhument toujours des corps de
victimes vous donnez à lire au grand
public votre analyse sur les
responsabilités de l'État français dans
ce
génocide du 7 avril au 4 juillet
1994 1 million de TS ont été massacrés
par le gouvernement rwandais et les
milices
outou historien des génocides Vincent
Duclerc en 2019 vous présidez une
mission de recherche commandée par
Emmanuel Macron et plongé dans les
archives de l'histoire du génocide pour
vous la France a demeuré aveugle face à
la préparation de ce génocide notre
constat de ces responsabilités accablant
de la France qui n'a rien compris qui
n'a effectivement qui n'a pas mesuré la
gravité de de de de son action Randa qui
effectivement a contribué à au processus
génocidaire sans le savoir une
responsabilité de la France tue PRS des
par les présidents sucessifs elle n'a
pas été complice mais la France a un
rôle une histoire et une
responsabilité politique au
Rwanda ces mots ont bien plus de valeur
que des
excuses dans votre ouvrage la France
face au géncide des le grand scandale de
la 5e République vous allez plus loin la
profondeur des liens entre le président
mitteran et le régime
d'abayarimana vous affirmez grâce à des
archives et des témoignages inédits que
de multiples alertes ont été lancé par
des militaires par des civils aussi mais
que dites-vous de nombreuses
irrégularités dont le président mitéran
son entourage et ses étatsmajors
diplomatiques et militaires sont
comptaable alors Vincent Ducler nous
avons une
question la France
aurait-elle pu arrêter ce
génocide réponse Vincent Ducler oui et
c'est effectivement le l'aspect
absolument dramatique qu'il faut
maintenant regarder très en face oui la
France pouvait absolument arrêter le
génocide elle pouvait l'arrêter je dir à
trois reprises premièrement lorsque le
gécide se prépare un génocide quand on
parle de 1994 c'est la phase
paroxysmique c'est effectivement un
million de morts en 100 jours mais pour
qu'il y ait effectivement cette phase
paroxysmique il faut qu'il y a une
préparation un processus génocidaire or
la France est très présente pendant que
se met en place ce processus et il est
mis en place par le régime que la France
soutient donc déjà à ce moment-là la
France pouvait s'imposer au président
abarimana obliger le président Rania à
cesser effectivement de d'encourager les
milices d'encourager la haine contre les
toutsis et la France n'a pas eu ce
langage de fermeté cette cette volonté
effectivement de faire plier et puis et
au moment des faits alors au moment des
faits avril mai juin est-ce que les
forces force militaire présente on est
un peu avant l'arrivée de la fameuse
opération turquoise si ordre avait été
donné à ce moment-là les massacres aux
machettes auraient pu être évités alors
ça c'est une grande question mais il y a
quand même beaucoup d'éléments qui
montrent que lorsque la France envoie
des forces spéciales près de 1000 hommes
pour évacuer les ressortissants dès le
lendemain de du début du génocide et
bien ces forces auraient pu avec
d'autres forces des Nations Unies il y
avait des casques ble on n'est pas dans
la situation de guerre mondiale où on
peut pas intervenir là il y a des forces
militaires occidentales très puissantes
qui auraient pu arrêter le génocide à ce
moment-là et la question doit t être
posé contenu de toutes les informations
si vous voulez c'est pas de reprocher 30
ans plus tard à des à des responsables
de ne pas avoir fait le travail ce que
le gouvernement savait auoncer
l'histoire de la raison d'État que vous
racontez dans dans ce livre il faut
revenir sur vos mots puisque la France
est à ce moment-là la la plus
massivement impliquée avec Kigali vous
parlez d'aveuglement
systématique qui commence avant le
génocide qui en fait n'a pas permis
alors qu'elle avait les moyens
d'intervenir alors que les alertes
étaient là et beaucoup d'alertes qui
sont les lanceurs d'alertes alors les
les alertes c'est là où c'est
effectivement très important et très
embarrassant quand même pour les
anciennes autorités et aussi d'une
certain manière rassurant aussi pour
notre pays c'est que les alertes elles
viennent de l'État elles viennent de
l'État elles viennent aussi du
gouvernement il faut souligner par
exemple le courage de du ministre de la
défense de 91 à
J qui je veux dire voit bien que c'est
n'est pas possible de continuer une
coopération un soutien inconditionnel
avec un régime un régime raciste
corrompu violent et donc ces alertes
elles sont aussi sur le terrain la tch
militaire de défense les les officiers
sur le terrain les diplomates si vous
voulez et donc toutes ces alertes elles
remontent et si on parle de raison des
taxes c'est que ce qui est dit de ces
alertes et ces alertes officielles de si
vous voulez de d'agents de l'État qui
font bien leur travail et bien c'est
écarté et il y a un moment bien sûr on
sait qu'il y a beaucoup d'informations
parfois on ne voit pas mais quand vous
avez des informations systématiques et
que vous les écarter parce que ça menace
effectivement une politique est une
politique penser exécutter à la
président de la République on est sur la
la Chaîne parlementaire le gouvernement
le Parlement sont totalement écartés je
veux dire même du contrôle oui oui parce
qu'il a fallu votre rapport il y a eu
des commissions d'enquête et vous le
saviez bien mieux que moi ici qui sont
pas allés au bout de de ce travail même
s'ils étaient importants ce que vous
dites va beaucoup plus loin pourtant dès
le 16 mai 1994 le début du génocide
c'est avril le ministre des Affaires
étrangères de l'époque à àin Jupé lâche
ce mot de génocide sans préciser
d'ailleurs qui est génocidaire mais le
mot est lâcher comment c'est possible
qu'au kedorset on ne puisse pas alors
qu'on sait ce qui se passe avoir un
avoir des conséquen sur le terrain al
moi jeis souligner que en 94 c'est la
cohabitation donc c'est certain que
François milerin ne peut plus plus avec
l'Élysée je veux dire avoir la main mise
totale sur ce qu'on appelle les domaines
réservés qui sont du reste pas
constitutionnalisés bon donc il est
obligé effectivement de partager et
c'est vrai que le gouverneur d'Édouard
baladure le ministre de la Défense
François leotard le ministre d'
affffaires étrangères Alain Jupé je veux
dire sont conscients quand même de ce
qui se passe et c'est vrai qu'Alain
jupet il faut lui dire courageusement il
reconnaît le le 16 mai le génocide des
TS et alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'il est pas du tout suivi en fait son
administration continue à à finalement
ne ne ne pas voir le génocide et aux
Nations Unies parce que la France est
membre permanent du Conseil de sécurité
et donc il faut attendre le 8jint pour
que des actes de génocide soient
reconnus par le Conseil de sécurité donc
si vous voulez ce qui est terrible c'est
que en fait tout était présent si vous
voulez au niveau de l'État allez-y
pardonnez-moi tout était présent voyez
au niveau de l'état des journalistes
faut penser aux journalistes sur le
terrain aux associations aux
intellectuels aux historiens pour queune
autre politique puisse être menée pour
arrêter le G decid ça n'a pas été fait
le nom de l'ex chef de l'État François
miteran n'a pas été encore prononcé
pourtant c'est absolument central le
Rwanda interroge le fonctionnement même
de la 5e République François mitéran est
au pouvoir vous parlez d'un pouvoir sans
partage sans contrôle avec des entorsse
à la Constitution et vous dites l'Élysée
à cette période mène une politique
j'ouvre les guillemets spéciale c'est
quoi cette politique spéciale oui c'est
une politique spéciale c'est une
politique qui vise à élargir au fond la
zone d'influence française que en fait
on sait que la France est puissante avec
ses anciennes coloniesaelle les pays du
champ le Burundi et le Ronda ne sont pas
des colonies françaises sont d'anciennes
colonie Belg et là il y a en fait une
volonté d'élargir l'Empire en fait d'une
certaine manière et donc comme
effectivement c'est quand même un sujet
on voit bien que le régime est très
décrié du reste les Belges partent parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas cautionner et donc
pour cela pour imposer cette politique
qui je veux dire suscite énormément
d'interrogations dans le gouvernement je
veux dire et bien il faut empêcher tout
contrôle empêcher et donc c'est c'est
vraiment un point essentiel l'exécution
des ordres de François mitteran qui
effectivement est le donneur d'ordre il
n'y a pas je veux dire de de de
militaire facieux si vous voulez bon et
bien l'exécution est réalisée à partir
de l'Élysée et donc on voit se mettre en
place un dédoublement des institutions
il y a toujours le chef d'étatmajor mais
qui effectivement doit accepter une
politique qui est vraiment fondée à
l'Élysée et tout ça si vous voulez c'est
pas de la reconstruction c'est les
archives qui l'ont dit et d'ailleurs que
vous revisitez avec des des documents
inédits ubert Vedrine est alors
secrétaire général de l'Élysée il ne
bouge pas non plus en fait il il ob au
président de la République hein je veux
dire voilà donc on a c'est pas la même
génération oui
enfin le prés de la République donne des
ordres je veux dire ut wedrine envoie
des notes des notes notamment des
étatsmajur diplomatique et militaire ça
revient et on voit que Françis mitteran
et on sait qu'il était malade mais sur
le sujet il est extrêmement percutant
c'est sa politique qui est appliqué
vraiment et par exemple dans le cas de
de de l'accueil de de la veuve du
président abarimana dont on sait que
semble-t-il elle est quand même assez
largement impliquée dans la préparation
du génocide he et bien c'est François
miteran dans un conseil rest desfance
qui dit oui monsieur le ministre de de
la défense c'est ma décision et on
effectivement on l'accueille en France
vous parlez d'une tentation algérienne
expliquez-nous comment la guerre
d'Algérie a-t-elle influencé la
stratégie française au Rwanda alors là
c'est aussi très intéressant parce que
euh en fait l'armée française a a
vraiment tiré les leçons dans les écoles
militaires dans le réglement des
officiers enfin de de de ce qui s'est
passé lors de la guerre d'Algérie au
fond de d'une armée qui qui s'est
transformé de donc en en opération
contre insurrectionnelle avec tout ce
qu'on a vu effectivement notamment la
dérive vers la torture généralisée donc
là il y a vraiment et les officiers sont
formés c'est pour ça que les officiers
français sont très mal à l'aise par
rapport à ce qui se passe mais en fait
ce qui va se passer à l'Élysée c'est que
on explique à François mitteran qui qui
effectivement le souhaite hein que on va
pouvoir tenir des pays des pays amis
hein avec des des forces spéciales avec
des quelque chose qui est très
différente et donc les la France
s'implique dans les affaires intérieures
c'est-à-dire que les toutsis ne sont pas
ne sont pas des des des des populations
ornaises comme on le dit ce sont les
tsis qui sont exilés qui attaquent
effectivement le gouvernement parce que
le le le pouvoir randais refuse
absolument il est t ennemi donc en fait
c'est c'est des affaires intérieures or
le le problème c'est que il y a une une
petite aile effectivement et moi j'ai
retrouvé des rapports qui avaient été
montrés dans la commission parlementaire
de 1998 mais l'ensemble du rapport
n'avait pas été révélé c'est le c'est un
rapport effectivement qui voilà tout à
fait et c'est un rapport qui montre très
bien que il faut aider l'armée rwandaise
à finalement lutter contre l'ennemi et
quand vous dites l'ennemi et ben tout le
monde surtout au Rwanda parmi le papup
majoritaire ou tout l'ennemi c'est le
toutsi et le toutsi qui est totalement
je veux dire sans armes désarmé il y a
pas de me qui toutsi il y a rien et en
fait ces personnes vont vont subir un
enfer ils vont être exterminé oui
jusqu'à cette colline bicé ù les où les
où les soldats de turquois sont présents
pourquoi le dénis a été si long sur ce
génocide et sur les responsabilités je
vous cite lourde et accablante que vous
documentez pourquoi ce déni a-t-il duré
si longtemps et qu'il est fait attendre
au fond 2021 et votre rapport alors
notre rapport et aussi il faut quand
même la commission d'enquête à
l'Assemblée aussi peut-être euh oui
alors qui a été très désant 98 beaucoup
d'éléments sont montrés du reste ce
fameux rapport effectivement Cusac est
révélé pas Canovas pardon son rapport
Canovas mais les conclusions c'est la
France a aucune responsabilité et ça ça
va durer jusqu'en 2019 où le président
Macron décide je veux dire de de de
permettre à des historiens de voir
toutes les archives et c'est quand même
une volonté politique hein c'est c'est
important à souligner et je veux dire il
y a une réussite à Kigali du président
de la République et les paroles de Paul
kagam sont assez fortes quand même de ce
point de vue làà c'est une réussite
diplomatique pour vous ça y est depuis
les mots d'Emmanuel Macron on est sorti
définitivement du déniis il naurait pas
fallu qu'il s'excuse ou qu'il demande
pardon en tout cas bah c'est ce que Paul
Kagamé a dit et moi je pense qu'il a au
fond sur ces questions là il faut dire
la vérité et il avait le président de la
République avait je ve dire une base des
des éléments de vérité à travers notre
rapport il est allé porter à Kigali et
il a il a il a redit nos conclusions et
et donc de ce point de vue-là moi je
pense que c'est c'est quand même un
exemple de de de démarche diplomatique
fondé sur la c'est un peu ce qu'avait
fait Jacques Chirac enfin c'est même
complètement ce qu'avait fait Jacques
Chirac pour le veldif donc pour revenir
sur le dénis pourquoi il y a eu dénis
c'est parce que effectivement les plus
hautes autorités de l'État sont quand
même impliqués dans une politique
spéciale qui finit très très mal c'est
pour ça qu'on est que le le le
sous-titre de mon livre c'est le grand
scandale de la 5 République c'est parce
que en fait c'est ce système
antionstitutionnel d'une certaine
manière le gouvernement est totalement
écarté du sujet et bien ce système de
raison d'État et bien bascule je ve dire
dans dans le génocide voyez parce que
encore une fois et on revient à la
question initiale oui la France avait
tous les moyens diplomatiques politique
militaire pour arrêter le génocide merci
beaucoup Vincent Ducler merci d'être
venu nous répondre c'est un livre
important vous l'avez compris la France
face au génocide des touts ça va au-delà
de votre rapport c'est une contribution
aussi au au débat public pour que chaque
Français s'empare de cette de cette
histoire là à l'heure et on n pas eu le
temps d'en parler où ce mot de génocide
est quand même beaucoup utilisé
peut-être à tort et et à travers vous
restez avec moi Vincent Ducler on va
terminer avec les parties pris de nos
affranchi il vous vous faire réagir j'en
suis sûr on les accueille tout de
suite et bonjour bertramb bonsoir plutôt
bertr Perrier installez-vous bonsoir
Mariette darigrand sémiologue avocat
commentateur des mot de la semaine et de
l'actualité on va commencer par action
planè comme chaque vendredi c'est la
chronique écolo de Léa Falco bonsoir Léa
bonsoir alors la mérite Paris veut faire
payer plus cher les conducteurs de
grosses voitures avec une votation ce
dimanche mais c'est quoi déjà SUV
rappelez-nous ah SUV bonne question
sport utility vehicle donc ça vient des
États-Unis ça c'est exporté en Europe et
ça marche bien alors la catégorie est
pas complètement définie mais ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que c'est des voitures
qui sont plus larges plus lourdes et
surtout plus haute que leurs équivalents
en berline ou en compact et en fait
c'est de là que vient le succès c'est
que ce sont des voitures hautes donc on
a le sentiment de dominer le trafi donc
d'être plus en sécurité au moins et
c'est là que c'est paradoxal tant que
tout le monde n'a pas un SUV et pour la
mairie de Paris les véhicules qui sont
concerné c'est les véhicules de plus
d'une tonne 6 dans le cas des thermiques
et des hybrides et de plus de 2 tonnes
pour les véhicules électriques alors la
marie de Paris veut faire payer plus
cher les SUV électriques moi je
comprends pas je me dis que c'est plutôt
bien pour le climat les SUV électriqu
pourquoi payer plus c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça alors sur le principe
il y a pas de doute l'électrique par
rapport aux thermique en terme de
consommation de production de CO2 c'est
meilleur sur l'ensemble du cycle de vie
c'est-à-dire de l'extraction des
matériaux jusqu'au recyclage de la
voiture c'est ce qu'on voit à l'écran
une électrique c'est moitié moins de CO2
émis en Europe parce qu'on a une
électricité partiellement décarboné
qu'une voiture thermique sauf qu'il y a
d'autres facteurs à regarder et
notamment le poids en fait ça a du sens
hein mais plus un objet est lourd plus
une voiture est lourde plus elle prend
d'énergie pour se déplacer moins elle
est efficiente et donc dans le cas des
SUV c'est que le SUV moyen il demande 20
% d'énergie en plus qu'une voiture plus
petite pour se déplacer et ça c'est
quelle que soit la motorisation
électrique ou termique et il y a un
autre critère qui est que ce sont des
véhicules plus gros donc forcément vous
avez d'autres questions que simplement
l'impact carbone ou environnemental déjà
en terme de place simplement de
stationnement dans l'espace public c'est
des places qui souvent n'ont pas été
conçu pour des pour des formats SUV de
pollution au particules puisque c'est
des véhicules plus gros ils émettent
plus de particules au kilomètres
parcourus et puis en terme de sécurité
surtout hein parce que des par-chocs
plus haut ça veut dire des par-chocs
parfois à hauteur d'enfants et
paradoxalement plus de risque pour les
piétons comme pour les automobilistes
lors d'une collision avec un SUV alors
qu'est-ce qu'il aura comme effet ce vote
quel sera son impact bah moi quelque
chose que je trouve particulièrement
intéressant c'est que on a toujours dans
les questions écologiques ce débat entre
la responsabilité individuelle du
consommateur et la responsabilité du
producteur là on a l'occasion pour les
Parisiens d'envoyer un message aux
constructeurs automobiles français de
leur dire bon le segment des grosses
voiture qu'ell soi électrique ou
thermique c'est pas un segment d'avenir
ce que par ailleurs les constructeurs
chinois notamment ont parfaitement
compris donc envoyer ce systèmelà ça
veut dire que le mieux pour l'industrie
française un segment porteur au niveau
international c'est de se réorienter
plutôt vers des petite voiture
électrique et quelque chose comme ça ça
fait boule de neige en fait parce que à
partir du moment où un certain nombre de
petites voitures électriques sont acheté
notamment par les entreprises qui
forment le plus gros parc aujourd'hui en
France et ben vous avez factuellement et
manuellement plus de voitures
électriques de petite taille qui
arrivent sur le marché de l'occasion et
donc ça se répand progressivement en
France donc je sais pas s'il suffit de
traverser la rue pour trouver un travail
mais en tout cas dimanche il suffira au
parisiens de traverser la rue pour
pouvoir voter contre les SUV quelque
chose me dit que vous n'avez pas de SUV
Vincent Ducler c'est pas votre style les
grosses voitures ou je me trompe j'aime
beaucoup marcher quand on peut marcher
et c'est il faut retrouver effectivement
la ville à travers à travers la marche
le piéton de Paris alors on enchaîne
avec avec vous Bertrand vous vouliez
revenir sur l'adoption cette semaine en
première lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
d'une proposition de loi destinée à
créer un nouveau délit le délit
d'omicide routier de quoi s'agit-il oui
alors aujourd'hui vous le savez Myriam
lorsqu'il y a un décès au cours d'un
accident de la circulation et bien la
plupart du temps il est appréhendé par
notre droit sous la qualification
domicide involontaire pourquoi
involontaire parce que sauf très
marginalement lorsque une personne
délibérément fonce sur quelqu'un pour la
tuer et bien la plupart du temps même le
pire chauffard ne veut pas la mort et
donc la mort est considérée comme
involontaire sauf que un certain nombre
de proches de victimes d'associations de
victimes ont considéré que cette
qualification d'involontaire était
choquante était inaudible insupportable
et notamment ne rendez pas compte des
situations où l'accident survient parce
que le chauffard conduit sous l'emprise
de drogue d'alcool en excès de vitesse
et donc évidemment le plus grand la plus
grande victime de cela et et l'un des
plus grands promoteurs de cette nouvelle
loi c'est le chef Yannick Aleno qui a
perdu son fils précisément dans un
accident de cette nature on alors
qu'est-ce qu'il changerait ce texte si
il était adopté au Sénat alors en
réalité ce texte il il changerait
d'abord une sorte de symbolique une
sorte de sémantique puisque il y aurait
une sorte de troisème voie entre
l'homicide involontaire et l'homicide
involontaire on crée l'homicide routier
à situation spécifique et bien
dénomination spécifique et donc
désormais lorsqu'on occasionne un
accident mortel parce que on est sous
l'emprise de supéfiant d'alcool parce
qu'on roule trop vite parce que on roule
sans permis parce qu'on roule avec le
portable à à l'oreille et bien on n'est
plus passible d'un homicide involontaire
mais d'un homicide routier et
effectivement cette qualification
domomicide volontaire apparaissait
complètement en décalage avec des
situations où des conducteurs prennent
volontairement le volant en sachant
qu'ils font courir un risque aux autres
usagers de la route et ce mot de
involontaire euphémise minor atténu
presque banalise des drames familiaux
évidemment inextinguibles et il ne
rendait pas suffisamment compte de la
réalité et nous le savons bien et la
phrase de de Camu mal nommé un objet
c'est ajouté au malheur du monde et
pourtant il y a des juristes qui
considèrent qu'elle ne sert à rien cette
loi une coquille vide oui alors certains
le disent parce que c'est vrai que la
modification est essentiellement
sémantique c'est l'ajout d'un nouveau
mot mais le régime juridique de
l'homicide routier est en réalité en
très large mesure calqué sur celui de
l'homicide involontaire les peines sont
quasiment les mêmes et donc c'est vrai
que elles sont déjà peu appliquées et
donc on se demande un peu pourquoi on a
créé cette catégorie su généris qui est
juridiquement en réalité pas très
différent de celle qui existait déjà on
aurait pu espérer qu'il y aurait des
efforts sur les délais d'indemnisation
sur le suivi des victimes il y a pas ça
dans la loi et finalement c'est assez
curieux que la même semaine on a appris
cela et on a appris aussi le nombre de
morts sur les routes en en 203 en France
métropolitaine
3170 c'est encore trop donc là on a une
loi qui est un symbole il faut passer
aux actes hm hm le symbole pe parfois
accélérer le passage aux actes merci
beaucoup Bertrand on termine avec vous
Mariette bonsoir à vous en pleine crise
agricole vous avez logiquement choisi
comme mot de la semaine agriculteur oui
je voulais m'interroger sur ce mot
agriculteur surtout en le comparant à un
autre que l'on a entendu beaucoup aussi
dans les médias paysan alors qu'est-ce
qui les distingue finalement donc il
faut se poser la question en fait
agriculteur est un mot moderne
c'est-à-dire datant du 17e 18e siècle
tout est relatif et l'agriculteur c'est
celui qui reçoit une terre un des agris
c'est ça les terre les champs à cultiver
donc il est du côté du travail et de la
technique et au fil du temps les
agriculteurs se sont peu à peu
industrialisés d'ailleurs leurs
tracteurs aujourd'hui sont des outils
très techniques donc c'est cette
industrialisation qui à votre avis
explique qu'il s'oppose au aux
écologistes oui je crois parce que les
écologistes réactivent une autre figure
qui est celle justement du paysan
ancestral alors c'est une figure
beaucoup plus dans notre imaginaire
collectif pur et dur dans la nature pas
dans la culture et l'industrie et du
coup il il est doté un peu de de qualité
de qualité un peu un peu mythique et
puis comment dire identitaire d'ailleurs
dans paysan il faut entendre déjà le
pays alors au sens de on est pays on est
de la même région mais aussi le pays
national donc c'est très identitaire et
du coup quand il y a des crise c'est ce
mot-là qui arrive on a parlé des colères
paysannes que 90 % des Français
soutiennent et les Français disent aussi
qu'ils ont tous au fond des racines
paysanes voilà alors elles sont vraies
ou elles sont symboliques ces racines
hein c'est vrai que notre pays s
beaucoup plus développé par
l'agriculture que par l'industrie comme
l'Allemagne ou l'Angleterre mais aussi
il y a eu tout un travail des écrivains
des photographes he pensant à de pardon
toute une notre culture notre fiction a
mis en scène cette magnifique ruralité
et puis aujourd'hui bah il y a les néor
ruraux alors pour terminer Miriam ce que
je dirais c'est que entre les deux
figures du paysan l'agriculteur
aujourd'hui la modernité c'est pas Léa
qui va me contredire elle est liée au
vivant elle est moins liée à la nature
qu'à ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le viv
et ce terme est arrivé dans la crise
actuelle donc c'est comme si un trè
Laron arrivait un vivantologue ouis qui
serait à ce momentl encore à construire
si l'agriculteur a de l'avenir et bien
c'est comm c'est parce que il va réussir
à incarner cette figure là du vivant
merci beaucoup vous êtes plutôt paysan
ou
agriculteur ce que je ce que je note
c'est c'est c'est l'évolution voilà de
des mots hein et comme vous avez
mentionné génocide génocide intéressant
parce que c'est un mot à bar Baris
c'est-à-dire c'est le juriste Raphael
Lemkin qui pour la convention donc qui a
été signée à Paris la Convention des
Nations Unies crée un mot pour définir
la volonté de détruire un groupe donc
groupe Genos donc en fait c'est la
racine grecque et sideré c'est
l'assassinat la racine latine c'est
intéressant que ce mot qui est
aujourd'hui on le voit tellement débattu
aussi et bien renvoie à une création
linguistique extrêmement importante et
renvoie aussi à un grand texte fondateur
celui de de la convention signée à Paris
au Palais de cadero le 9 décembre 1948
1948 on s'arrête là vous vous allez je
suis sûr plein de choses à vous dire en
dehors de ce studio pardon d'être en
retard merci les affranchis pour vos
chroniques c'est le weekend profitez
bien et à la semaine
[Musique]
prochaine